[Music]
all right so from the job market to the
extremely hot las vegas housing market
we caught up with an expert about the
latest trends among millennials and
others who are looking to buy across our
state in the country
moving to our great state of nevada
comes with a lot of benefits for working
people no income tax for retirees no tax
to your 401ks iras and pensions big
reasons why we've seen an influx of
people to our state and why the nevada
side of lake tahoe is appreciating a lot
quicker these days than the california
side a lot of sellers in california are
moving because they don't want to be in
california anymore paulina rishikov is
the senior director of research for
sunday a company that advertises houses
for sale to the highest bidder of
investors she monitors all trends across
the country what's different now is that
we've been under building for such a
long time if you look at the averages
compared to population growth we built
about half of the homes we were supposed
to build to keep up with the population
housing construction has lagged since
the great recession in the years leading
up to 2007 there was more home
construction than there was demand low
interest rates easy credit and toxic
subprime mortgages led to the housing
bubble and a financial crisis now we've
got buyer demand but not enough new
homes it definitely is not healthy with
low levels of inventory we haven't kept
up with millennials coming of age and
home buyers ship and this will also
impact gen z
but since the great recession there's
been an uptick in the building of
multi-generational homes currently more
than 50 million americans live with at
least three generations of family
members under one roof and recently more
family members have been helping those
younger members secure that first home
the baby boomers can help their kids buy
that first home right they can give them
down payment money and you can see that
in some of the reporting as well
she adds while multi-family units grew
nationally over the past decade a new
report out today shows they did not hear
in las vegas they were down about 26
percent between the year 2020 and 2021.